hi everyone my name is vincent
and this is a photo of me in this series
of videos
i am going to explain psychic learn to
you
psychic learn is the go-to library for
machine learning with an amazing
ecosystem of plugins
and in this series of videos i will
highlight some of the most important
parts to understand
if you're going to be working with this
tool what's important to note is that
these videos i'm about to show you
originally appeared on calm code this
website features short videos about a
topic
in a series so what i've done is i've
concatenated the videos about
scikit-learn together
for this free codecamp video
that means that this long video is split
up into different sections
and each section will highlight a
different but
relevant so i could learn topic now note
that all the code for the videos that
you're about to see
is available on github you'll find a
link in the show notes
and you can download each notebook
yourself locally to run them
but you can also use a service like
google colab as well
so let's talk about the topics that we
will be discussing in this video
in the first section we'll discuss some
high level topics involved with psychic
learn
they are mainly there to help you
appreciate how to construct machine
learning pipelines
but the videos will also try to help
explain to you why machine learning
is still hard in practice after all
machine learning tends to go beyond just
optimizing a model
after that we've got a segment where we
will talk about pre-processing tools
you can use a scikit-learn model but the
performance of the model
really depends a lot on how the data is
pre-processed
and understanding this pre-processing
step tends to make your models a lot
better
next if you want to judge a model you'll
also need to think about how to quantify
its qualities
so in this section we'll talk about the
metrics that scikit-learn offers but
also how to build custom metrics to get
your machine learning models on
for your own specific use case after
that we're going to discuss
meta estimators the idea here is that
while you can pre-process
data as a step in your machine learning
pipeline you sometimes also want to
apply
post processing in order to properly
explain this though
we will have to discuss these things
called meta estimators
then finally i would like to demonstrate
a machine learning library
that integrates with scikit-learn that
tries to make machine learning a little
bit more
human the tool is called human learn
and full disclaimer it's a tool that i
made
myself the goal of this library is to
show you
how you might be able to benchmark the
domain knowledge that's inside of your
company
before you resort to machine learning
now i hope that these topics indeed
sound interesting to you
but let's now get started with
understanding psychic learn
psychic learn is possibly the most used
machine learning tool in the world
and in this series of videos i would
like to explain the general flow
of how to use scikit-learn when you want
to make predictions
now for reasons that will become clear
later we are going to use a very
specific version of scikit-learn
in this series of videos in particular
we'll be using version 0.23.0
and if you're in a jupiter notebook you
can use this command to make sure that
you've got this
specific version installed it should
also be said that this
series of videos is different than some
of the other series of videos on this
website
in this series of videos it is extra
important that you watch
all of the videos not just the first few
you actually need to watch all of the
videos to get a proper understanding of
how to use
scikit-learn appropriately also the
scikit-learn ecosystem is vast
and it's impossible to do it justice in
just a short
series of videos the goal of this series
of videos
is more to give you a bit of an overview
on how in general
you should think and work inside a
psychic learn but there will be
other series of videos that will go more
in depth in a certain aspect of psychic
learn
that i will not be able to do justice in
just this series of videos
that said let's dive in the way
scikit-learn works
is you start with some data you then
eventually give it to a model
the model will learn from it and then
you will be able to make predictions
that's the general flow however let's be
a little bit specific
just giving data to a model is a bit
vague so
what do we mean by giving data to a
model
now typically if we have a data set
that's useful
for predictions then we can split the
data set up into two parts
and the common notation is to call one
part of the data
x and the other part of the data y
now typically my data set x represents
everything that i'm using
to make a prediction and my data set y
contains the prediction that i'm
interested in making
the use case that we're going to deal
with in a moment has to do
with house price prediction so you can
imagine that this
y data set that contains the house
prices
and x over here contains information
about the house things like square feet
how big is the garden that sort of thing
if you split your data up in this
fashion
the next thing that you can do is you
can pass that to your model
and then it's the model's job to learn
the pattern such that we can predict y
using x this x and y notation
comes from scientific articles and
because of the notation that
scikit-learn adheres to it's also the
notation that i will use in my videos
what we'll do next is go back to our
notebook and get ourselves a data set
that psychedlearn provides
that gives us our x and y
given that we have scikit-learn
installed what i can do is i can say
from
sklearn datasets
i can type load press autocomplete and
then i see a whole lot of data sets that
are at my disposal
and these data sets are meant for
benchmarking and educational purposes
and what i'll just go ahead and do is
i'll load the boston data set
that's a data set that contains house
prices of boston i believe in the 70s
now if i call the load boston data set
as is
it's going to give me a dictionary with
lots of items in it
however there's a parameter that we can
set called return xy
and if we set that to true then we get
two
arrays out
one array represents the house prices
and these house prices
are in thousands of dollars and these
are all
properties of the houses one nice thing
that i can do is i can type
x comma y equals and then i've got my x
and my y
that i can go ahead and use inside of a
scikit-learn model
so what we are about to do is
make a model appear inside of
scikit-learn but just conceptually it is
nice to point out what a model does
actually
when you create a model it hasn't seen
any data yet
there has to be this moment where we
declare that this model over here
learns from data and in scikit-learn
that means that there are two phases
there's phase one where we create the
model
and then there's phase two where the
model has to
learn from the data in scikit-learn all
models are just python objects
and then this learning over here in
psyclearn terminology
that is often called the dot fit step
and during that fit step we typically
pass it the x as well as the
y data set it's important to know that
these are two separate phases that the
model has to go through
if we wanted to be able to make
predictions but given that we've
highlighted this overview let's go back
to the notebook and show you what the
code might look like
so let's load up our first model scikit
learn comes with
many but one of my favorite ones is the
k nearest neighbor
model and you can find it in the
neighbors
sub module and i will grab this k
neighbors regressor now for the creation
step
what i will do is i will have a variable
called model
and that will point to this model object
now at the moment there hasn't been a
phase where the model was able to learn
anything
so if i were now to call model.predict
x as in hey model could you perhaps
predict why
using x then right now i will get an
error
and that's because the model has not
been fitted yet
however if i were now to say hey model
please fit yourself
x comma y now by calling this
k neighbors will learn from the data as
well as possible
such that if i now wanted to make a
prediction it is able to do so
and you can verify yourself that the
number of predictions that we're making
is equal to the number of rows in our x
array now i'll discuss later what this
machine learning model does exactly
because you might wonder how the
predictions get made
but one thing i would just briefly like
to point out is that i can also use
another model
say from scikit-learn linear model
i'm just going to import linear
regression
but the beauty of psychic learn is that
even though this is a
completely different machine learning
model that internally works
very differently the api is still
exactly the same
if i were now to replace this k
neighbor's regressor with this linear
regressor then i can run all the cells
and sure the predictions will be
different because it's a different
model the internals work differently but
the api is exactly the same
it's still.fit don't predict and it's
this what makes scikit-learn very nice
to use
you can stick to a general api and not
have to worry too much about the
internals
and that is very nice
so i'm back in a jupiter notebook and
what i've got is my trusty
k nearest neighbor model and i am
fitting that model
such that later on i can make
predictions with it and what i've got
now is this
array of predictions but what i've also
got is this array of original values
these were the true values so the same
so one thing that i typically like to do
is just make a scatter plot
i will show the predictions on the
x-axis
and the predicted values on the y-axis
and by looking at this we get a bit of
an impression of how well the model
is doing it's just a plot but it does
give me an impression that in general
it seems to pick up something of a
signal and that there indeed is some
form of correlation happening as well
when our model says the house price
should be high it seems to be
high in reality as well it's not perfect
though and
it's a little bit noisy here and there's
a couple of reasons for why that may be
but let's now talk about how this
k-neighbor's regressor works
let's consider a simpler version of the
data set
and the data set contains a square feet
that a house has as well as let's say
the proximity to school let's say it's
these two
and let's assume that if you have a big
house
and proximity to schools is relatively
small then
these red dots indicate that these are
indeed the
expensive houses and you can imagine
maybe the cheaper houses being over here
now the way that a prediction is made
when you're using a k neighbor's
regressor
is let's say i want to make a prediction
for
this point right over here now what the
model will do
is it will start looking for its nearest
neighbors let's say we're looking for
the nearest five
i suppose that will be these
if i look at the distance from the point
that i'm trying to predict
to all the other points in this data set
i think these might be the nearest
neighbors
now the prediction for this data point
will be the average of these five
neighbors that we found
and that is how a prediction is made but
here is where the tricky thing can
happen it might be that the proximity to
a school here
is in miles and it might very well be
the case that
you might have one mile over here two
miles over here
and three over here but these square
feet that we have on this axis
well that can be well in the thousands
so that means that the distance that
will be used to find neighbors
will be very different on this axis
compared to this
axis because
this x-axis just features larger numbers
it also means that that axis will have a
much bigger effect in our end
predictions
and that might not be what we want so
this means we have to rethink
what our model actually is
at the moment this is our high level
overview of what a machine learning
model is
still data going into the model and then
we get a prediction eventually
but maybe we have to rethink what a
model exactly is here
because if i think about the example
that we just saw
maybe before this data set x
goes into this model over here maybe we
would have to do some pre-processing
first
we saw that the square footage can be in
the thousands and maybe school proximity
can be
in singletons so there might be
something to be
said about applying pre-processing
before it touches the model
so let's draw that so here's the redrawn
schematic
the idea is that we take our data set x
and before we give it to our k
nearest neighbor we apply some sort of
scaling
just to make sure that the effect that
each column can have on the prediction
is on the level playing field and doing
this
will make this k nearest neighbor
predict
rather differently and when you think
about it that way
maybe we need to redefine what we think
a model
is before we said that it is
this k nearest neighbor that is the
model but maybe
we should expand that idea
maybe everything inside of this box is
the model
if the pre-processing has a large effect
on the model itself
then for all intents and purposes we
would like that to be part
of our entire system so that said
maybe it's more this pipeline that i've
drawn over here
that should be regarded as the model and
it just so happens that
in scikit-learn we have this notion of a
pipeline
and this pipeline also has the api
where we can call dot fit on the entire
pipeline
as well as dot predict once it's trained
the reason why that is so nice is
because
this pre-processing step also has to
learn from the data
in order to properly scale and normalize
and by putting everything into
a pipeline we are able to just handle
that
automatically such that we still have to
interface with one object
instead of many so i hope this overview
paints a clear picture of why we like to
have a
new definition of what a model is and
what i'll do now is i'll just implement
this in the jupyter notebook
so let's first import the parts that we
need from scikit-learn i will need to
import
from the pre-processing module something
that can do
scaling and for that i will just use
this standard scalar object
next what i'll do is i will also import
the pipeline object and that allows me
to chain
processing steps after each other so
what i will do now
having imported these tools is start a
new pipeline object
it needs a list of tuples and it's a
pair of a name as well as a step
do keep in mind that you have to pass
the object over here
not the class so it's important that you
use these brackets after we've done
scaling we would like to use our
nearest neighbor
and this is the pipeline what i can now
do is just call pipe.fit
x comma y and this entire pipeline will
now
train and fit itself and what i can go
ahead and do
is i can replace the model that i had
originally over here
with the pipeline that's now also scaled
and when i run this we should see a new
graphic appear as well
so i don't know about you but this does
look a bit better
because there's less noise there is
one other issue though that we've just
introduced
so let's have a look at what's actually
happening now because we're cheating
i'm telling the pipeline to go ahead and
predict using this data
set x but note that that's the same data
set that we're using
in the dot fit moment we are learning
from the same data
as we are judging on and the k nearest
neighbor will do something now that's
cheeky
suppose that i want to make a prediction
for a point that's let's say over here
what i will then do is i will grab the
five nearest neighbors
and then i will make a prediction for
this one point
by taking the average but we're not
making a prediction like this in our
scatter chart
the point that i'm trying to predict is
a point that's in our original data set
as well
so what we're actually doing now is
we're saying suppose
i want to predict this point what are
the nearest five neighbors
and well the nearest five neighbors
would include these four points
as well as this original point so that
means that i'm literally
using the data point that i'm trying to
predict in order to figure out
if i'm doing the prediction well as far
as judging whether or not a model is
good
this chart over here is giving us a view
that is too optimistic
and i can force it too
what i'll quickly do now is i'll just
change the pipeline a little bit
to emphasize what's currently going
wrong this k neighbor's regressor
has a few settings and in particular we
have this number of neighbors that we
can set
so let's change this number from five to
one
and i will run every single step now
again
just to show you what the effect is
if i only select one neighbor then the
chart
falsely suggests that we're making a
perfect prediction
but the model here is only able to do
that because it's allowed to memorize
the original data
the nearest neighbor here is the
original data point
so this chart doesn't tell us anything
about how it might predict points that
are not in the original data set
and this is a big issue we want our
model to predict data that it's not seen
before
and we cannot trust charts and
statistics where the model is allowed to
predict on the same data that it's
trained on
and that brings us to two issues
the first issue is how can we get a fair
comparison going for ourselves
but perhaps another issue is how do i go
about
picking an appropriate number of
neighbors here and when you consider our
thoughts like this
you might realize that we have to review
our understanding of what a model is
one more time currently this is our
belief of what a model
is we have this pipeline and there can
be multiple steps inside of it
but now we have another issue because
now we might have
some settings for the k nearest neighbor
i might want to try out the system where
we have one neighbor or two
all the way up until 10. and i would
like to pick this
number of neighbors setting such that my
model makes the best predictions
and in order to figure out which
predictions are the best
one thing that we can do is we can
compare our prediction
with the original label but as we've
seen in a previous video
we have to be really careful here we
don't want to judge the model
on the same data set as we're learning
from
and with that in mind maybe we should do
a trick with a data set
just to keep the methodology clean and
here's the idea
i'm going to cut this data set up
into let's say three different segments
and what i'm also going to do is i'm
going to copy both data sets three times
and here's the idea first i'm going to
say well let's give this
the predict name and let's do it over
here
i'll set the predict name here in the
second
set and i'll put predict down here
in the third and i'm going to declare
the other parts for training
the first time around this part
of the data set is going to be used for
training
and then given the trained model i can
use this portion
of the data that's not been used for
training to test how well my predictions
are going
and in the next data copy
i'm going to repeat the exercise but a
different portion of the data
is going to be used for prediction as
well as training
and finally the same thing happens here
as well
the idea here being i'm going to call
dot fit
dot predict here but i'm fitting on the
green part
and i'm predicting on the red part
this prevents me from ever predicting on
data that i've used during
training but it does allow me to judge
in the predict section of my data how
well my predictions are
and the idea essentially is if i just
repeat this
then maybe i'll have a pretty good
metric of performance for when
i had one neighbor selected when i had
two
neighbors selected and when i had 10
neighbors selected
however in scikit-learn all of this
is something that the pipeline will not
handle for you
instead there's a different object
and the name of this object is a grid
search
cv object the idea behind it is that you
can give this grid search a pipeline
and you can also give it a grid like
this number of neighbors over here
and internally it will perform
cross-validation
which is the procedure that i've
explained here
and by performing this cross validation
we have a methodology that is somewhat
sound
and what i would argue here is that
maybe this grid search object
maybe that is the model that we should
be thinking about
and in scikit-learn also this grid
search has a dot
fit as well as a dot predict
method attached so let's turn this
pipeline
into a proper grid search the first
thing i'll need to do
is make sure that i have my grid search
cv object imported
and you can import it from sklearn
model selection and the object that
you're interested in is this grid search
cv object
and given that we have this imported now
what i can do is i can start a new grid
search
object to get started with it i need to
pass an estimator
and an estimator is something that has a
dot fit as well as a predict
and the pipeline that i've made earlier
this one over here
will do just fine next what i gotta pass
is a parameter grid
and this parameter grid is going to
represent all the settings that we would
like
to go over in our pipeline in particular
the one that we're interested in
changing is this
number of neighbors in this k neighbor's
regressor
now to set the grid we need to have the
name of that parameter
and the easiest way to get there is to
use the
getparams method that is on every
scikit-learn
estimator including this pipeline
and when you run this you will see all
the settings that you're able to tweak
in particular you'll notice that there
is this
number of neighbors property
that's on this model and the name
model that i have here corresponds with
this name of this pipeline step here
and the number of neighbors that i have
here corresponds with
the number of neighbors that are a
parameter
in this object over here for our intents
and purposes though
the only thing i need to grab is this
one but know that you can grab
more here if you would like to change
more parameters
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say hey you know what
these are all the values that i would
like you to check
and i would really like this grid search
to also do cross validation
so let's set the cross validation
parameter to three
and now this is my model
oop forgot a comma there
now as far as grit search goes i would
like to mention that
what we're doing in this one over here
is relatively basic
i will leave links to other video series
where we're going more in depth
but the main thing that i want to give
you as a high overview of
what will you end up doing when you have
a grid search like this
well you are simply just gonna call
model.fitxy just like every other
estimator we've seen so far except in
the grid search what will happen is
we will have all sorts of settings and
cross validation that's happening on our
behalf
so we don't have to write that code
ourselves however
once this has trained there is this very
interesting property available called
cv results and note that this property
ends with an underscore
the grid search will train and for every
cross validation for every setting
it's keeping track of a couple of
numbers
and what i can do is i can just give
that
dictionary that we have as output there
to a pandas data frame
and here what you see is all sorts of
statistics
you see how long it took to fit the
entire thing
and for every parameter that we have
and for every cross validation split
that we've made
we can see how well it did on a certain
score and we can also see which result
was the best at this point in time it
seems like
we found that this might be the best
setting and that's interesting
and at this point in time we can spend a
little bit of time
analyzing this generated data set to
figure out why that might be
the main point i'm trying to make so far
though
is that with only a very small amount of
code over here
we have a fairly mature pipeline
and we also have a proper set of lego
bricks to build machine learning systems
and if you'll be using scikit-learn a
lot this is the pattern that you are
eventually going to be aiming for
we have a proper pipeline that we can go
ahead and tweak quite easily
it's clear what steps are happening the
steps are reproducible as well
and as far as methodology goes we can
argue that we're doing a couple of
things right because we're using this
grid search object over here
so try to stick to this pattern whenever
you're using scikit-learn
the system of fit predict that
scikit-learn offers and the way that it
allows you to construct pipelines
is something to appreciate
that said though we could ask ourselves
have we now found a model that can go to
production have we done our work
are we now proper data scientists and
the answer is
no and i have to highlight why
and this is also the reason why it's
very important that you watch
all of the videos in this series
so far we have been using the
scikit-learn api appropriately
now i use the word appropriately here in
the sense that we've been using its
building blocks in the right way
we click together a pipeline where
you've been using a grid search
and so far i would argue these are all
good things
as far as an approach to a data science
project though we could not have done it
worse
and i would like to explain to you why
we've been using this load boston data
set
but during the entire analysis we've not
taken any time
or even bothered to look what's actually
inside of this data set
now when i just run load boston like so
you will notice that i get
a dictionary one of the things inside of
this dictionary is this description tag
and what i can do is i can get a
description of all the variables that
are in the data set
now if i want to get a nice output i
have to print what is
returned to me here so i'll do that and
what i can now do is i can have a
little look at what we're actually
dealing with so first of all you can
kind of wonder
is 506 houses
enough to give us a lot of confidence in
our model
maybe not we can also ask ourselves the
question hey from
what year is this data it might be that
this data is really old and that the
world has moved on
in a way that this data set doesn't
really represent what's currently
happening
that's also a valid concern but
it gets worse we also never bothered to
look
at what attributes are actually in the
data set x that we're using to make a
prediction
so we have things like crime in the
neighborhood we have things like
how industrious is the area but the one
that i was really concerned with that
when i first looked
at this is this one apparently this is a
data set
where the proportion of blacks in your
town is something that is actually being
used to predict a house price
now i don't know about you but i'm
having a really hard time coming up with
a use case for this data set
that is appropriate looking at this
feature it's
clear to me that we have a potential for
a racist algorithm
and that is a property i don't want to
have in production
now there's a lot of things that can go
wrong when we deploy a machine learning
model
and we've discussed methodology and
these are fine topics
it's good to worry about that but grid
search is simply
not enough and what has been bothering
me is that this data set has been used
for so long
in so many different courses without
even looking
at the variables that are in here
putting a model that has
this feature in it is incredibly naive
and i think as a profession it really
helps if we just do better
this is also why scikit-learn has now
chosen to
remove this data set load boston
after a few releases will be gone
and this was the reason why i had to pin
the version number of psychic learn in
the beginning
mainly because the load boston data set
in a future release
will no longer be available remember
this chart that we made halfway in this
video series
it contains our predicted values versus
our true values
and this chart was generated because we
were using the same data set that we
trained on
as we evaluated on and the danger here
is is that the chart suggested that our
model was better
even though the model was effectively
leaking information
if we had blindly trusted this model
then the risk is that this model might
have gone to production with very high
expectations
and the results clearly would not have
been great the only way to catch these
sorts of things in practice
is to remain skeptical you should always
feel free to distress the model
and to try to test every weakness that
you can come up with only after a long
period and lots of stress tests
are you allowed to put a little bit of
faith into the model that you have
and note that the same thing that
happened in this chart also happened to
us while we were doing the grid search
the grid search introduced a methodology
and
we certainly have statistical concerns
when it comes to a model if it has poor
predictive power then
it won't be very useful in practice but
we should maybe
mention here that there is a danger in
doing this grit search
it may give you the impression that
you're doing the right thing
after all numbers go up and you might
get optimistic about the quality of your
model
and it's exactly this optimism that
might be causing you to develop a blind
spot
it's the time during which you make
these optimistic charts as well as when
you see numbers go up in your grid
search
that you forget to think about things
like hey what's actually in my data
and i hope the load boston data set as
we've seen in the previous video
makes it clear that you cannot just
blindly put any data into a model
you actually have to spend some effort
and try to understand what you have at
hand
there are many things that can and have
gone wrong in the application of machine
learning models
and i would argue that it's also your
responsibility to educate yourself to
make sure that it doesn't happen to you
if the output of a machine learning
model is your responsibility
then so is the data going in
so please use scikit-learn and its
amazing lego brick-like features but
also understand that so i could learn
typically is the easy part of the
profession the hard part is
understanding the story
behind the data set and to understand
what might go wrong
when you put a model into production and
that means that it will be good
to make sure that you're up to date on
themes of ethics
in algorithmic design but also topics
like feedback mechanisms
and to consider fallback scenarios for
when things go wrong in production
that concludes the psychic learn portion
of this video
this would be a good time to grab a
drink or have a quick break
and in the next portion we'll talk about
pre-processing tools
inside of scikit-learn
quite typically in scikit-learn you'll
have your labels
and you'll have your data that you want
to use to make a prediction
and then both of these eventually will
be passed to
a model and then you'll have something
that is able to make a prediction
but the idea of what a model is can be
extended here
because if you think about what happens
more often than not it's a pretty good
idea to first
transform your data that you're using
for the prediction
and the reason for doing that is because
the model performance will just be a bit
better by doing so
so what i figured might be a good idea
was spend some videos explaining some of
the
more frequent transformers that people
tend to use
and also show that it's important to not
forget about these transformers because
they do really matter in your pipeline
so what i've done here is i've started
the notebook i've imported numpy pandas
and blackpotlib and i've imported this
dataset called drawdata1
and it's a csv file it has a column x a
column y and a column z
and z has two values either a and b
and the idea is that these are just some
numeric numbers and we're trying to
predict this one column over here
and using mapp.lib we can show what the
dataset looks like
so we've got a group of data points over
here
and another group of data points over
here
and we should notice that there seems to
be like a small group of outliers over
here
as well as a small group of outliers
over here
but another thing that you should be
aware of
is that the y-axis over here is on a
completely different
scale as the x-axis over here
and that can be something that's
bothersome
the effect that these axes will have
depends on your algorithm
but in general you can imagine that
algorithms are sensitive for this kind
of thing
so a large chunk of your pre-processing
in this case
is going to revolve around scaling
we want to rescale this data such that
there's still information in there
but it's just numerically a bit more
stable because the x and y axes are just
a little bit more in line with each
other and as you might be able to guess
from the name
a standard way of doing this is using
the standard scalar
from scikit-learn and what it does is
for each column
it is going to calculate the mean
as well as the variance the idea here
being that if you have a data point x
and you subtract the mean of x from it
and then you divide by the square root
of the variance
well then you're going to have something
that revolves around zero
and this will also have a variance
that's kept at bay
so what i'll now do is i'll just go
ahead and use the standard scaler to
rescale the data set that you see here
to use a standard scalar we first have
to import it
and next what we have to do is we have
to create a scalar object
but from here we should be able to call
fit transform
and give it our data set x and this will
be
our new transformed data set and what
i'll just go ahead and do is i'll just
copy this plot code over here and put
that down here
this way i can just feed it the new
values for x
and we can see what it looks like so one
thing you should notice at this point
is that these axes numerically are
much more similar
but it's not exactly perfect though it
seems that
this spread is about eight units
whereas the spread over here is more
like
three and a half and we can also observe
that there's nothing really happening
with these outliers
so the standard scaler is doing things
we like but it does make you wonder
is there maybe another way of scaling
this
to further demonstrate what might be a
weakness of the standard scalar
i figured i would generate a data set to
make the point just a little bit more
tangible
so what i've got here is just some data
that has a couple of outliers on one end
and what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to say well let's take that data
set
let's subtract from that the mean of the
data set
and let's then divide by the standard
deviation
and whenever i run this i have slightly
different data because i'm simulating
data
but as i'm running this over and over
you should notice a few things
and yes for starters definitely the
numbers we have here on the x-axis
these are definitely scaled
so you could argue that's a good thing
but the downside is we still have
outliers
and depending on the algorithm that
you're using outliers will
make life a little bit harder for you so
let's instead conceptually come up with
a different way of normalizing
where these outliers are just a little
bit less of a problem
so let's say that this is my original
data set
now what i could do is i could calculate
the mean value
which would probably be around here and
i could then say oh let's standardize
around
that but let's calculate some other
values instead
let's let's ignore the mean for now
instead what i could do
is i could calculate the quantiles i
could imagine for example that the 50th
percent quantile is over here
and that means that 50 of all the data
is on this side of the line and 50 of
the data is on that side of the line
i could imagine that maybe the 25th
quantile is over here and that means
that 25
of all the data is on the left side and
75
is on the right side and i think that
the 75th
quantile will be somewhere over here and
let's say the 99th that might be over
here this is something that we could
go ahead and calculate and if i were now
to think
hey how can i project that onto
something that's normalized
well i could have a number line down
below
and i would have the number 50 halfway
the number 100 would be
all the way to the right the number zero
will be over here i would have 25 over
here and 75 over here
and i hope you can see that there's a
mapping here
and notice when i scale it this way that
then in this
scaled representation the distance from
the outlier to the
75th quantile is a lot smaller
and that means that by using quantiles
as opposed to means and standard
deviations
we may be able to get a more robust
pre-processing step
if there's outliers in here so let's use
this idea as a pre-processing step
and see what the effect is on our data
set
so from scikit-learn pre-processing i
can now
import the quantile transformer and what
i'm going to go ahead and do is i'm
going to replace the standard scaler
with that quantile transformer but
before i run this
notice the axes
the numbers that are the minimum and the
maximum and also notice
these outlier clusters i'm now going to
run this and
show the effect now there's a warning
typically scikit-learn likes to
calculate a thousand
quantiles and the data set that we gave
it doesn't have
enough data for it so what i'm just
gonna go ahead and do
is turn that number of quantiles
into a hundred but notice
that the minimum as well as the maximum
on both
axes are exactly equal to zero and one
and you might also recognize that the
clusters that we saw earlier
are still in the data it's just that
they have less of a profound effect
and the reason for that is because now
we're using quantiles to transform and
scale
as opposed to using the mean and
standard deviation
in the previous video we showed that
when you take
your x matrix and you pass it through a
transformer
the quantile transformer that you can
get a very different
output and what i would like to show in
this video
is that when you take that output and
then pass that to a model
that then the predictions are also going
to be very different
so what i have done is i have made this
plot output function
and what the function does it allows you
to pass through
a transformer and the function will then
run all of this
it's going to train a model a k nearest
neighbor model
and it will then also produce some
predictions and i just would like to
show you
what a profound effect this transformer
can make in a predictive pipeline as
well
so i'll first run it with a standard
scaler
and what you can see here is the
original data that we start out with
followed by the transformed data and
then we will see the predicted data
which is this final plot over here
and what you can see is that everything
around
this area over here would get predicted
as the yellow class
and pretty much everything else will be
predicted as the purple one
let's now compare that to the quantile
transformer
because the transform data is much less
influenced by
the outliers you'll notice that the
model is bound to think
that there's just this dividing line
between the two classes and that's how
we're gonna
classify everything and if i were to
compare the predicted data plot
you'll really see a big difference
and in this particular case i might
argue as far as numerical stability goes
the quantile transformer does have
benefits
but it would still be a good idea to
verify this with a grid search
but i hope that you can imagine that the
quantile transformer even with the grid
search
is just gonna be more stable in the long
run
because these groups of outliers are
not gonna have as much of an effect
anymore
let's now have a look at a different
data set in this case i'm looking at
dronedata2.csv
and this dataset is special in the sense
that
it's a dataset that represents a
classification task
that is not linearly separable
it's not possible for me to draw a
single line
such that on one side of the line i'll
have purple points
and on the other side of the line i'll
have yellow points
and this might make you think that a
logistic regression is not going to be
the right choice for this task
you may need to have a different
algorithm here to get a good classifier
so let's see if that is accurate
so what you see right now is a pipeline
that has a quantile transformer first as
a pre-processing step
and then a logistic regression and the
best thing the logistic regression has
been able to do
is come up with this line to separate
the two classes
and this is obviously a bad classifier
these two groups should be the same
color and the line should not separate
this way
but maybe we can fix this with
preprocessing
instead if i consider the two axes that
i have at my disposal here
then essentially what is happening is
the logistic regression will get
x1 and x2 and at the moment it can only
use those two columns
to come up with a separating line but
what if i generate
x1 times x2 as another feature
that's something that the logistic
regression might be able to use
and what about x1 to the power of 2 and
x2 to the power of 2.
what you could say is that we can limit
ourselves to the linear features
but we can also just use those linear
features to come up with
non-linear features that our model might
be able to use
so let's change the pipeline
such that we add these features in as
well and then see what the effect is
from scikit-learn pre-processing i can
import the
polynomial features and just start a new
object over here
now note that i'm not changing any of
the input variables here but one thing
that's nice to point out
is that i am only calculating the
interactions at the moment
and i'm only calculating this for a
degree of 2 but i could increase this if
i wanted to
but let's just see what the effect of
just this is
booyah and if i were to scroll up now to
compare
i would argue we have a near perfect
classification
and granted this is on the train set so
it's cheating a little bit
but what i do hope to have shown here is
how much of an effect
a single pre-processing step could have
in your pipeline
the effects can actually be quite
drastic
so far we've been doing a lot of
pre-processing on numeric data
but you can also imagine that we have
data that's like this where
maybe we have classes low medium high
risk
and then it will be nice if we can do
some pre-processing
such that this text data becomes numeric
data as well
the most common technique for that is
the
one hot encoder now what this encoder
will do
is it will be able to take in
an array of text or categories and
transform that out
to something that is indeed numeric now
if you just run this
as is you're going to get a data
structure that's known as a sparse
matrix
there's a setting though that we can
change such that
the sparsity is false and then we can
actually see what is inside of it
note that the first two rows are
indicated as low
and we can see that indeed they share
the same column
then we see high over here which
is listed there and then we see medium
below and that is listed there
so we can see a form of correspondence
and that is something that is indeed
useful
and the most common use case for this is
if this is let's say the class that you
would like to predict
then this numeric representation
that is going to be the y array that
you're going to pass to psychic learn
because this is something that cycle
learn can use to train numerically on
there is some behavior to be aware of
though
and this is not super relevant if you're
generating labels
but it is relevant if you're using this
onenote encoder to encode information
for
the data that will predict the label
let's say i grab the encoder now and i
ask it to transform something and what
i'm asking it to transform
is something that it's never seen before
so notice that i'm asking it to
give me a label for zero but zero does
not appear
in this set and that is the set where
we did perform a fit on so we might
wonder
what's going to happen here well we're
going to get a big fat value error
so it's saying value error found unknown
category 0.
so essentially it is telling us you're
not allowed
to give me data that i've never seen
before
we can change the setting for this
though because at the moment the
handle unknown parameter is set to error
but we can change that such that it's
set to ignore
and now if i run this it's not going to
give me an error
and what it's doing is it's saying well
these are all zeros
or another way of saying that zero is
neither low
high or medium so we can just go ahead
and give it this
zero array back now one thing to finally
note about that is that this is a very
useful setting
if you're generating your x matrix so to
say
but you don't want to do that if you're
generating your y
labels because those are things that you
want to have very strict control over
in this series of videos i've shown you
some of the pre-processing steps that
are available
but a very convenient way for you to
play around with more of them
and to get a better understanding is to
go to this website called
drawdata.xyz and full disclaimer it's a
website that i made
but it's a website that allows you to
quite
literally make a drawing of a little bit
of data
and that way you can play with it
from your jupyter notebook and playing
with preprocessors is the best way to
learn about them
now what you can go ahead and do from
here once you've drawn your data set
that you're interested in
you can click this download csv button
to download this file locally
but what you can also do is you can copy
the csv to your clipboard
what you can then do is you can type
pandas.read
clipboard and then this will be able to
read from your clipboard
the only thing you have to do manually
is you gotta set the separator to a
comma
because i think the clipboard is
typically reading in from excel
but what i can now do is just run this
and lo and behold
the data set that i was just drawing is
now available to me here
and this is a really nice way to just
get a little bit playful with
scikit-learn pre-processing steps and
pipelines i hope that this series of
videos
has inspired you to check out these
pre-processing steps
a little bit more in depth but mainly i
would like you to remember that these
pre-processing steps
really do matter they can have a
profound effect on what your algorithm
is going to end up doing
and that concludes the pre-processing
part
of this video next we will move on to
metrics i was looking around for a fun
data set when i found one
on kaggle it's a relatively well-known
data set about credit card fraud
and i figured it'd be a nice example to
explain something about scikit-learn
because kaggle is giving me a data set
and this data set consists of a label
that i would like to learn
as well as the data that i'll be using
to predict that label
and typically you would start building
your model but you're not going to build
one
typically you're going to make a few
so you're going to have model a all the
way down
to model z and these models might be the
same type of model
but they're going to have different
hyper parameters and for all intents and
purposes
they will be different models because of
it and all these different models are
going to have
a different prediction
and what we would like to do is pick the
best model
and in scikit-learn you would use a grid
search for this and what the grid search
will do
is it will take all of these predictions
and it will compare them against our
original label
using a metric
and it's important you get that metric
right select the wrong metric
and you're going to pick the wrong model
so i figured it'd be useful to spend a
few videos
explaining how psychic learn goes about
this
metric because it is a really important
part of your machine learning pipeline
so let's check the data set before we
talk about metrics
i downloaded the data set into a csv
file that's on my downloads folder
and i'm reading it in with pandas and
the data set is a little
bit big so i'm only reading in the first
80 000 rows
the data set has a lot of columns and
most of them are
anonymized
at the end of the data frame we see a
class that's the thing we're interested
in predicting accurately
and we see an amount the idea behind
this data set is that we have all sorts
of anonymized features
that's represented by column v1 all the
way down to
v 20a but all these features describe
characteristics of a transaction
and we also know the amount that was in
this transaction
now to get this data frame into
scikit-learn
it helps to have it in numpy and that's
what i've done below
x contains all the columns that have a v
in it and y
is the column over here what i'd like to
predict
and to emphasize what kind of data set
this is let's
print some useful information so let's
print the shape
and let's also list the number of fraud
cases
so this looks like data that's ready for
scikit-learn but
we have to be aware of one phenomenon
and that is the fact that the number of
fraud cases
you know it's about 200 and that is out
of 80
000 cases so it's safe to say that this
data set
is unbalanced there are way more cases
with
fraud than without and that is something
to keep in mind
so keeping that in mind let's start with
a simple model
and i'll just use logistic regression
for now
so first i'm going to import it
and then i'm going to say hey please fit
on that
data and make a prediction as well
now when i run this i get an error
saying that the
total number of iterations has been
reached and what's probably happening
here is that because this data set is so
imbalanced
it's not converging within the number of
iterations that it has
so what i'll do is i'll just set the
maximum number of iterations to be
higher i think the number of iterations
initially is a hundred but let's set it
to a thousand
okay so that works what i'll now do is
i'll take the sum over all of the
predictions that i have
so this is by no means a perfect metric
but what i would like to observe now is
if i'm overfitting on just the train set
then the model detects fewer cases
than i actually have in my data set
so without grid search i can already
tell that this model could be doing
better
so let's add a setting that might allow
us to
move the algorithm in the direction that
we're interested in
and for logistic regression one
convenient way of going about that is to
say hey
let's specify the class weight now the
class weight is a dictionary
that allows me to specify how much
weight to assign
to each class and in particular the way
that you should read it
is that for class 0 that will be the
non-fraud cases then we assign a weight
of 1
but for my class of one which would be
the fraud cases
i'm saying well let's give that double
the weight the idea being that we're
gonna
get more fraud cases selected so let's
run this and see what the effect is
and booyah i'm able to find more fraud
cases this way
so this is a pretty good place to start
i have a setting here that i would like
to optimize
and that means that right now i can
start worrying about the grid search and
about the metrics
so now that this basic example works
let's get a grid search going so we can
find the best value for this
class weight and i'll start with basic
settings
let's first import it
and next let's define our grid search
i'll first need to pass it an estimator
and that's our logistic regression in
this case and
let's also set the maximum number of
iterations to a thousand
the next thing i have to do is i have to
set the parameters
and i'm interested in changing this
class weight
so now i have to give it a list of
settings to loop over and in particular
the settings have to be dictionaries
like so
and let's use a list comprehension for
that
so next let's specify how many cross
validations we want to do and
i'll just say 4 for now and
i have a couple of cores on this machine
so i'll set the number of jobs to -1
and that way this grid search can occur
in parallel
my grid is now defined and what i can do
is i can tell my grid to go ahead and
fit
and it's done training so i'll start a
new cell here
because this grid object it has a cv
results
property now and this contains all of
the results from the cross validation
and that's a dictionary with lots of
values
but i can easily turn that into a data
frame
so when i look at these results i see
the class weight appear
and i also see the scores
so for every cross validation split we
see this
score and it's this score that grid
search is using to pick the best model
but then we gotta wonder how has it come
up with this score
because we didn't specify any metrics in
our grid search
yet it is able to find this score right
here
look there's no metrics
now where that score comes from is from
the
model i've got a logistic regression
right here
and what i can do is i can ask for the
scoring method that is in there
so we see that there's a bound method
called score and if i use
two question marks then i can see the
implementation of it
so this is the implementation and i see
a doc string
and if i look at the implementation it
says that
from metrics it's importing the accuracy
score internally
so that means that this logistic
regression
it has a score and unless we specify
otherwise
the score for logistic regression is
just going to be accuracy
and when i look down below
at this mean test score then that makes
sense
the model is predicting no fraud most of
the time
so we're getting a really high accuracy
there
but this is not the metric that i might
be interested in though
so let's change that so let's
import some things from the scikit-learn
metrics module
and in particular i'll just import the
precision score
and the recall score
now the way these score functions work
and i'll take precision as a first
example
is you can pass it the true values
those are the values that it should
predict and you can give it the
predicted values so i'll just predict
some
and so far so good i can do the same
thing with recall
now precision and recall both measure
different things
what recall will tell me is it will tell
me
did i get all the fraud cases and
precision is saying
given that i predict fraud how accurate
am i
and you can imagine in an extreme
example if i were to say
hey let's predict that every single case
is a fraud case
well then the recall score is going to
be really high and the precision score
is going to be really low
in another extreme case suppose i find
one candidate that's a
fraudulent candidate but nobody else
gets predicted as fraud
then i'll have a really high precision
and a really low
recall and you can imagine that if
you're going to optimize for either of
these two
you're going to get a substantially
different algorithm and in this case the
crux is
do we care more about false positives or
false negatives
for now i'll assume that we care a
little bit more about precision
so what i will do is i will take these
two metric functions and add them to the
grid search
now let's add precision and recall to
the grid search
to add it to the grid search we have to
pass a scoring dictionary
and i can say hey i've got my precision
score
and i've got my recall score there's one
extra thing we have to do though
and that is if you want to use these
functions inside of a grid search
then we have to pass that to the make
score function
first we'll discuss later
why they make this distinction but by
doing this
we now say hey let's add these metrics
now as well
the one extra thing that i have to pass
now as well is the refit
if i just tell so i could learn hey
these are the extra scores that i want
you to keep track of
scikit-learn will do it but if i want
this grid search to select the best
model
based on one of these scores then i have
to explicitly mention
which score it has to optimize over
so let's run this and i just ran
and one of the effects that you now see
is that we have
the test precision that's now listed
here
as well as a test recall score
one extra thing that we could add now is
these are the test scores which are
useful
but sometimes it's also nice to see the
train scores as well
so we can set a flag that we want to
also get the train scores in our cross
validation results
and if we now scroll all the way to the
back we should at some point see
yes scores for the train set as well
since the grid search is now pretty well
set up it will be good to do
a proper run so i will change two things
for starters i'm just going to increase
the number of cross validations
by having more cross validations this
will take longer to run
but we should have more accurate metrics
coming out
next what i'll do is i will replace this
range
4 with a numpy linear
space and that allows me to say hey
let's start at 1
let's end at 20 and let's have 30 steps
in between
this should give me a higher resolution
on the effect of this class weight
and again by setting this value v higher
i'm telling the algorithm to focus
on the fraud cases so i will now run
this
and when it's done running i'll show
some charts that summarize this
so it is now done running and i've made
a few charts
this is the first one it shows the test
results
we have the weight on this
axis of the class weight
and we see the two scores on the y-axis
and if you want to have a really good
precision you have to be on this end of
the spectrum
and if you want to have a really good
recall you have to be on this end of the
spectrum
and note that if you want to have a
balance between the two
now that you're somewhere in the middle
so this is interesting
but you might wonder what do the scores
from the train sets
tell us
and again we have our class weight here
and our scores but we get a completely
different picture
so it's a good reminder that
cross-validating results is a good idea
because i've got two metrics now
scikit-learn is able to optimize either
of them
so at the moment i'm able to either
optimize for precision
which is going to give me the model over
here with very very high precision
and very low recall or i can say hey
pick the model with the best recall
and then i have the opposite problem
maybe instead i want to be here in the
middle
and there are two ways of going about
that
one might be to go for another metric
that's inside a psychic learn
in this particular case the f1 score
is something that you might be
interested in because the f1 score
represents a balance between precision
and recall
but it might be more interesting instead
to make our own
scikit-learn does not support every
single metric out there so it is good to
be able to write your own sometimes
and in this case i think it might be
cool to have one that selects the
minimum out of the recall and precision
score
if i select the best model based on this
metric then
i will have a model that balances the
two
so let's go and implement this
now you might remember that the
precision score function that we had
that's the function that we're using
over here but the signature of that
function
was that we said hey there's these true
labels going in
and there are these predicted labels
going in and the output of this function
was a number
so let's use that as a template to
create our own
and i will call this the min recall
precision
and if i want to calculate the minimum
between precision and recall
i'll first calculate the recall next
i'll calculate the precision
and then i'll return the minimum of the
two
let's now add this to our grid search
i'll just call that the minimum of both
and again i gotta pass that to the make
scorer
and let's now also say that the grid
search has to refit on it
let's now run this
it's done running now and let's have
another look at the charts
i updated them while the grid search was
running
so one thing that's interesting is it
does seem that the
grid search would now pick a model
that's around this region over here
i can't exactly see where but it makes
sense it's close to where the two are
balanced
so that's interesting but you might
wonder
well the green line well that green line
that's
always lower than either of the two
i might wonder well why is that i'll
leave it as a small exercise for
yourself to figure out why
and you can check the appendix for the
answer in the previous video
we've made our own metric here
and then we used it in the grid search
over here
but before we were able to use it we
first had to pass it to this
make scorer function and it wasn't just
our own function we also did this for
the precision and the recall as well
so what's up with that
so to show what is happening there let's
make
a scorer using our min precision recall
function
and then just let's just have a look at
the implementation
so the make score function apparently
takes the min recall precision function
that we had
so that's this one and it takes that
function
and then turns it into a predict scorer
object and it has a signature
in goes an estimator x y true
and some form of sample weight
so one way of looking at this is to say
well
we start with a metric function that
accepts
y true the true labels and y
predicted the predicted labels and what
makes score
is doing is it's turning that into
something else some other callable
object
where i can pass it the estimator my x
data set
my entire y labels and a sample weight
as well
and this is what the make score function
does
the idea behind it is that sometimes you
would like to use the function this way
if you're in a notebook and you just
want to quickly use a metric
then calling that directly can be useful
but it would be a shame if you had to
rewrite that function
such that the grid search would be able
to use it because the grid search likes
to have something callable
where you also have access to the
estimator now
what i just quickly want to do is
rewrite this
function over here such that i no longer
need
make scorer just to demonstrate that
this is indeed the case
and we'll do that using this signature
over here
so i've copied the signature this is now
the input
and let's now fill in this function well
what i can do
is i can first calculate the predicted y
values from this estimator that is being
passed in
so that means i can just say s dot
predict
and now i should no longer need this
make scorer
so let's run this
and it ran and let's now just check if
we get the same chart
excellent when you're looking at this
min recall precision function then
there's probably a lot of parts that you
recognize
for example the estimator that we have
here
that is going to be a logistic
regression like we've defined here
with the correct settings for the class
weight and and you can also imagine that
we have this
x here and this y true and that these
will be
the train or test set labels and data
sets
but you might wonder well what's up with
this sample weight over here
in sample weight well that's an extra
feature that can be passed along
certain machine learning models allow
you to say well this row
is more important than this other row
that's different than the class weight
the class way that we have over here
that says
hey this class should get more attention
but the sample weight allows us to pass
data
that says this row is more important
than that row and in the case that we're
dealing with fraud
where we have rows that resemble
financial transactions
you could maybe say that maybe the
transaction amount
maybe that's a valid setting the really
big transactions that have millions of
dollars in it
well sure if there's fraud there that's
much more important
to catch than if it's only about a
single dollar
so one thing that i could do is i could
rewrite this entire function
to take that sample weight into a count
one thing that i would need to do though
is i would also need to give a sample
weight
and that's something i have to do over
here so let's say i'll do that
and what i can do here is i can say hey
take that original data frame
and take the amount column that is the
amount of the financial transaction
and just for numerical stability what
you can do is you can also
maybe not take the exact amount but the
logarithm of it
this way if you have really big
transactions then you prevent that we're
overfitting on it
and what i'm gonna do now is i'm just
gonna run this and i'll leave this the
way it
is i'm not changing this
if i have a principled way of taking
that sample weight and
translating that to a metric i want to
optimize then that is definitely
something i can now do here which is
good
that's a benefit that gives me
flexibility but i
don't have the financial expertise to
come up with a good rule now
so what i just want to briefly show is
if we actually do this
what is the effect because even though
we're not changing the metric
adding this effect will change the
algorithm
so i'll run this now and show you the
summary charts to
see what changed
so just for reference this is the
original chart
and this is where the balancing point is
between precision and recall
and let's now see how this compares so
the dashed line is where the balance was
before
and the dotted line is where the balance
is now
so adding sample weight will definitely
influence the algorithm here
but it's good to know that we could also
use the sample weight for our metric
if we wanted to
so let's consider a new approach to this
problem
we could consider that perhaps fraud
is like an outlier
it's a rare event but it's also
something out of the ordinary
so one could wonder sure we can have a
classifier go in there
and predict whether or not something is
fraud but if we just have an outlier
detection algorithm
might that not correlate with fraud so
what i would now like to do
is replace the logistic regression with
an outlier detector
and then adapt these metrics such that
we can check
if this is the case
so let's first write a little bit of
code that can handle outlier detection
i'll just start by importing the
isolation forest
algorithm and because it's an outlier
detection algorithm
when i call dot fit it doesn't need a
label
it just needs the data set i can still
use it to make predictions though
so let's just run this when i look at
this output it seems like everything
here is a one
as if it's always predicting fraud but
that's not the case
to show that i'll just quickly import a
counter object
and i'll just count this how often a one
occurs and how often another number
occurs
and that's a thing psychic learn assumes
that a one
represents not an outlier and minus one
that that does represent an outlier
so if i want to translate these outlier
detections
what i got to do is i got to say well if
these predictions are equal to negative
1
then i want to have a 1 because that
indicates a label for fraud
and 0 otherwise now with that
observation done
let's just briefly go back here
and look at our metrics because a lot of
stuff now will break
these recall and precision scores they
expect
zero or one values at the moment not
negative one
so if i were to put an isolation force
here the metrics would break
that is unless i write my own
variant over here so i'll just quickly
go ahead and do that
and there we are i have made two
functions over here
that don't need the make scorer like we
saw before
and by doing it this way these
predictions are now turned
from outlier predictions into fraud
label predictions
what i've now also changed is i have
removed the logistic regression here and
put in the isolation forest
and i have now also put in the
contamination factor here
as the hyper parameter that i want to
tune again i'll not go into the details
on what that means
but we could say it's something i want
to optimize
finally the two functions i have here
again
are being put into the scoring methods
down here below
and here's the small amazing thing about
this
notice again that this isolation forest
when you train an isolation force you
call it
via fit and then you pass it an
x matrix without y labels per se
but because we are passing in y labels
below here
anyway we are able to use them here
in our own custom metrics and
that is something really flexible
that means that we can pass it because
that allows us to use outlier detection
algorithms
as if they were classifiers so what i'll
now just quickly do is run this
and then make a similar chart like what
we had before
so here's the similar chart on the
x-axis again we have our hyper parameter
and on the y-axis we have our scores
and when looking at this it does seem
that even though the outlier detection
algorithm
is able to detect some things it's not
able to detect
as well as the logistic regression that
we had before
that said this can still be a useful
feature to have in your pipeline
but that is outside the scope of these
series of videos
what is amazing here is that we are able
to use metrics
to quickly judge if an outlier model
would be
useful in this classification problem
in this series of videos i hope to have
been able to show you how you can use
metrics in your scikit-learn pipelines
and that it actually offers a very
flexible api
that said i do think it's fair to point
out that you don't always have to make
your own metrics
very often the metrics that scikit-learn
has will be relevant
to your project too you can have a
scroll around
there's metrics for classification but
also for regression
and it's definitely worth to spend some
time here on the documentation page
before wrapping up though i do want to
point out one
small danger with the current approach
the way that we model things is by
taking our data frame
passing it through a grid search to get
our model while also checking the
metrics
and in terms of methodology this is a
fair approach
but there is one big danger and that's
especially true in the case of fraud
do we really trust these labels
especially in the case of fraud
it may be safe to assume that we don't
have a complete picture of all the fraud
cases
it's a cat and mouse game so when i see
a label for fraud
i think i can assume that that's
accurate but when there's no fraud
that might just be fraud that's
undetected and if we think a step
further probably the labels that i have
those are the labels of the easy cases
those were the cases that got caught
and if we then train a model that
optimizes for the easier cases
then we have to be honest we might have
a model that has a blind spot
for the harder to detect fraud cases
so i must stress it is really important
that we
keep track of our metrics and that we
take that very serious because it has a
huge
impact on how we pick the model but
typically it is not enough
we still need to concern ourselves with
the quality of these labels
because if the labels are wrong then so
is your metric
in the previous video we were using the
make
score function to take our custom
metric and to turn that into something
that the grid search was able to use
and before delving in depth in what the
make scorer function does
exactly i figured it'd be good to point
out that when it comes to customization
there's
a couple of settings that you can still
add not every metric
will have the rule where greater is
better
if you take mean squared error for
example in that case
greater will be worse so that is
something you want to specify
otherwise the grid search might pick the
wrong model
and there's also metrics that depend on
having a
probability measure being there as
opposed to just a class
and if you need the probability measure
for your metric that's also something
you got to specify
so for example let's say i take this min
recall precision function
and if greater was worse for this metric
you could specify greater is better is
false
and then you would pass this in your
grid search
now note that this is of course a bit of
a detail
but there will be moments when you need
it so i figured it'd be good to at least
mention it
let's now move on to a relatively fancy
feature of psychic learn
the ability to work with meta models
usually in scikit-learn what you'll do
is you'll make a pipeline
and that pipeline will have
pre-processing tools
maybe some featurizers and after that
you'll have
a machine learning model
and the idea is that this pipeline is
just a very convenient way to
connect everything here however if you
think about
what you might want to have happen
inside of a pipeline
then there might be some steps you would
like to have after
you've made your model maybe there's
some post processing you would like to
do
the way that the scikit-learn pipeline
works however is that you're able to
have many featurizers and pre-processing
tools
chained together but at the end it stops
with this
model the thing that can do fit predict
that should be the final thing in your
pipeline
so that might make you wonder how can we
go about some of these extra steps
and post processing tools we might have
things that we would like to grid search
so it will be nice if there's a trick up
our sleeves that allows us to
still have access to these sorts of
techniques in our scikit-learn
pipeline over here now it's a bit of an
advanced trick
but the way to go about this is to think
about
meta estimators
psychic learn has a few of them but
there's a lot of them implemented in
other tools like scikit lego
full disclosure this is a tool that i
made but the idea is to have an
estimator
that can take this model and add extra
behavior to it
it's a powerful modeling technique so in
this series of videos what i would like
to do
is highlight a few of these meta
estimators and show you
how you can use them to make your
modeling pipelines a bit more expressive
scikit-learn has a classifier that's
known as the
voting classifier and it's an example of
a meta estimator
to help explain what it does though
let's consider this classification task
it's definitely an artificial data set
i'm using the make classification method
to generate it
but what you can see here is that i've
got these blobs of yellow points
as well as purple points and what you
can see
is that there are some purple points
around here where there's mainly yellow
points
and vice versa there's also a few yellow
points around here
now there are two kinds of models i
suppose that you could make here
if we were to say train a logistic
regression on this data set
then effectively what the logistic
regression would do is it would pick the
direction
where it can make the most difference
and then create one separating line
in this case it probably will have a
separating line somewhere over here
and it will say that everything on this
end of the line is supposed to be the
yellow class and everything on this side
of the line is supposed to be the purple
one
a different algorithm nearest neighbor
would do something slightly different
whenever it needs to predict a point
let's say a point over here
it would look at all the neighbors let's
say the nearest five
and then make a prediction and that
would mean that in this region over here
it might predict a purple point and
where the logistic regression is a
little bit
too general as in it's splitting up
everything here on the left and the
right
you can imagine that the nearest
neighbor is maybe too specific at times
and you might want to have a way to
balance these two things out
and being able to balance these two that
is something that the voting classifier
can do
the idea behind the voting classifier is
that you can give it a list of
estimators and you can also give it a
weight
for each estimator and that might allow
you to say well
i want this estimator to be weighted
twice as heavily
as this one the nice thing about this is
that this weight over here is something
that you can use inside of your grid
search
and that's really nice because that
means you don't manually have to specify
these weights
you can have the grid search determine
the best way to balance different models
for your data set
and here's an example of how the voting
classifier works
on this data set i've got my voting
classifier over here
that i've imported beforehand and then i
kind of submit
something that resembles a pipeline it's
a list of tuples with
the name that i associate with an
estimator and then
the estimator itself note that the first
classifier going in here is this
logistic regression and the second
classifier over here is this k neighbors
classifier
but what i'm able to specify is i'm able
to say well
these are the weights i would like to
associate with both models
and i would like you to do soft voting
and soft voting over here effectively
means that
we are averaging the predict proba
values now to show the effect of this
i've created a couple of charts
this chart over here shows the original
data and this chart over here
shows the proba predictions of the first
model this one
and you can see we get the behavior that
we expect there's a
line that's separating everything and
you're either on the left hand or right
hand side of it
this chart represents the predictions
from the k
neighbors classifier and you can
definitely see
that it's zooming in on a couple of
areas we see darker colors appear
in the yellow region and we also see
lighter colors appear
in the dark purple region and what you
can see in this
third chart are the predictions from
this voting classifier
and you can see that we basically smooth
the predictions of these two models
what i can do is i can say well let's
give a
somewhat higher weight to the k nearest
neighbor
model and by doing that
you can see that these two charts are
now definitely more similar
but i can also give a higher weight to
the logistic regression classifier as
well
so there's two things to observe here
first of all
there's merits to having such a voting
classifier
you can combine different models that
work different ways this way which is
nice
but moreover the main thing that's
happening here code wise
is that we have an estimator here that
takes as input
other psychic learn estimators this
voting classifier is adding behavior
to both of these models and that can be
a powerful
modeling strategy note that if we put
this voting classifier
inside of a pipeline that this is still
the final model at the end of it
but we are able to add behavior because
models can be used as input here
and this way of thinking about models
gives us
a lot of flexibility and expressiveness
let's now say that we have a slightly
different data set
again it's an artificial one made with
the make blobs
function in scikit-learn but given that
we have a data set like this
let's now talk about a different
consideration for models
let's say that we have a logistic
regression that we'd like to fit on this
data set
you might get a separating line that's
somewhere over here let's say
the way that the separating line works
if i were to draw
it out on this axis over here
if i were to draw what the probability
is that my predicted value is equal to 1
which i'm associating with these yellow
points then the predicted curve would
look something like this
now what's happening here is we have a
threshold
around where the probability is larger
or lower than 0.5
when we actually say to which class a
point belongs to
you could wonder though what if we just
move that threshold just slightly
maybe move it somewhere over here
maybe at 0.7 if we were to do that
then this classification line would move
upwards
it would move over here
that's the new one and that's the old
one
now the consequence of doing this is
that your model might become
less accurate overall but whenever we do
predict that it's going to be a yellow
point
using this new line we're probably more
sure of it
in this region over here there's some
purple points and there's some yellow
points
in this region over here there's still a
couple of purple points left
but it's less so by tuning this
threshold over here
we might have a nice knob to turn to
exchange precision
and recall in our model and the ability
to do this
is provided by the thresholder meta
model that you can find in the
scikit lego package
the way that it works is similar to the
voting classifier
we have a meta model over here and as
input it accepts an estimator
in this case logistic regression
thresholder accepts
any cycler model but it only works
in binary classification cases what
you're then able to do is you can set
this threshold value over here
which again is something that you can
put inside of a scikit-learn grid search
and here's the effect
you can see that if we set a very low
threshold
that maybe the optimal line that we
would have had over here
kind of moves down a bit over here
this setting i assume will be great for
recall but bad for precision
and if we move the threshold to the
other direction over here
then we might have something that's very
high precision but very low recall
what i've got here is an example of how
you can maybe use this inside of a grid
search
i have my modeling pipeline over here
inside of that modeling pipeline
i've got my one model and this model
has this threshold parameter i can refer
to that using model
underscore underscore in my parameter
grid here which i am using in my grid
search
and what i'm doing is i'm just looping
over all sorts of values of this
threshold
and i'm keeping track of the precision
the recall as well as the accuracy
and if we scroll down to the results of
this grid search we see some interesting
things
the blue line over here represents the
precision
and if we look at the threshold value
then indeed it seems that the higher the
threshold the more picky we are
and then also the better the precision
is
as expected this does come at the cost
of this
recall over here which is the orange
line and we can definitely see it
plummet
whenever we have a high threshold value
now keep in mind that we're doing this
on the
test sets we're not reporting train
numbers here something that's
interesting is that for this particular
data set it seems that
as long as we remain let's say in this
range of thresholds
the accuracy doesn't really change too
much
but the precision and recall curves do
so that means that you don't have to
give up your accuracy
to get a bit of a boost in either
precision or recall
and the nice thing about this threshold
is that it's something that's easy to
interpret
and at the same time it's also a nice
example of what i would call
post processing in order to tune the
threshold
i need to have the model ready and it's
this sort of
post-processing steps that are probably
best implemented
as a meta model as a model that accepts
another model
as input what i've got here is a
somewhat large pipeline that is
predicting
the weight of a chicken over time it's
being applied to a data set that has
a diet column that says something about
what the chicken's eating
different chickens have different
foodstuffs and also
time the idea is that chickens gain
weight over time
but they might gain more or less
depending on the diet that they have
the way i'm going about that is i am
selecting the diet column
and i am one hot encoding that
next what i'm doing is i'm taking the
time column
and i'm just passing that through a
standard scaler
schematically what is happening is
whenever i get my new data set
it is going into this pipeline that has
a feature union
which is splitting up the features into
two buckets
the time feature and the diet feature
the time feature gets scaled
the diet one gets encoded and then this
becomes the
data set that i can use for my machine
learning and it's
this data set that is being used down
below here
for my linear regression and here's what
the predictions look like
for every diet you see a new prediction
line
now the downside of the way that we've
encoded our data
is that this linear regression sees the
one hot encoded variable for these diets
and the only way that it can deal with
it is to see it as
a constant shift and if we think about
the possible effect that a diet could
have
then i hope that you might agree that
we're not really modeling it
the right way here the effect of the
diet might be something else than
adding a mere constant so then the
question is
can we maybe reuse this diet in a
different way
maybe instead of adding a feature that
is one hot encoded for every diet
can't we maybe group per this diet
and then train a different model for
each
you would have model 1 for diet 1 model
2 for diet 2
etc and then maybe what we can do
is we can say well whenever there's a
new data set
x coming into this model
then what needs to happen is this
internal grouping needs to figure out
what diet this new data belongs to
and then make a prediction using the
appropriate model
this behavior can also be implemented as
a meta model
and scikit lego has an implementation of
exactly this
and here's an implementation and the
effect
in this case we have a data frame that's
going into this model over here
so that means that i can use the column
name here to describe the group
but if it was a numpy like data
structure then you can also refer to the
column indices over here
you'll note that when we do this the
effect of this diet
isn't simply a constant instead it's
training
a different linear regression each of
these lines has their own intercept
and their own slope and i hope that you
can imagine that making models this way
can be reasonable the main risk that you
have to keep in mind
is that it is possible that maybe one of
these groups
has way more data than another one of
these groups
so that is something to keep in mind if
you're interested in doing something
like this
let's now consider a time series task
there's a basic one over here
and one of the properties of this time
series is that it's also changing over
time
there's a seasonal pattern in here for
sure but the shape of the seasonal
effect
is definitely getting amplified as time
goes on
so let's say you want to maybe model
this one way of modeling this
is that we can say well let's have a
look at every month in the year
and let's try to calculate the mean of
every month
and then that can be our model and what
we can do is we can use the
grouped predictor for that as well as a
dummy regressor
and if we were to then calculate the
mean for every month
the prediction would look something like
this
again note that we're using the dummy
regressor from scikit-learn here
and the grouped predictor that we saw in
a previous video
when you have a look at these
predictions though you'll notice that
something is definitely off
it seems that we're really good at
predicting this middle here
but we're undershooting in the more
recent years and we're overshooting
in the far past so that means that we
have to wonder well
what can we maybe do here to make this
just a little bit better
and it's pretty good to observe that
this is something reasonably general
in this particular case i'm definitely
looking at a time series but it's not
unreasonable to consider that the world
is a moving target
no matter what you're trying to predict
there's something to be said to maybe
focus in on the more recent data and
maybe to forget the
data that's in the past now the
interesting thing is that
scikit-learn actually provides a small
mechanism to deal with this
not every model allows for this but some
models do
the dummy regressor is one of these
models though and what we're interested
in is a parameter that's tucked away in
this
fit method if you look at the signature
you'll notice that the fit method has
this simple weight
parameter it's a parameter that's set to
none in most cases
but what you can do with it is you can
say well how much do i weigh my data
points
let's say that this is my big input x
and my array y that i would like to
predict
then i can have another array of sample
weights and
what that allows me to do is it allows
me to say well
this data point over here that's worth
0.1
this one is worth 0.2 and maybe this
data point is worth 10.
the idea behind these weights is that
you can say that maybe this data point
is way more important to predict
than maybe this one or this one and if
you can specify this for every
row in your data set then this gives you
an option to customize
now for our purposes it would be nice to
have a meta model that can
automatically put values for these
sample weights
into whatever we're trying to predict
and in particular
something that's general is that we
might say you know what let's just do
some
exponential smoothing if we assume that
this data set here is sorted
such that everything on this end is the
most recent data and everything on this
end is the old data then maybe we can
say that there's a
decay parameter that says that
everything that's happening here is
super important
but as we move to the past it gets less
and less important
now this idea of adding a decay that is
a meta model
that's also made available by psychic
lego
and here's the implementation and you
got to pay attention because
we're actually using two meta models
here we're starting out with our good
old dummy regressor
but then we say well we want to add
decay to it what we're doing is we're
saying well
the more recent data points matter more
than the old ones
note that if you want to do this your
data set does need to be sorted
beforehand next what i'm doing is i'm
saying okay
take that model but now i want you to
calculate
the mean not on the entire data set but
per month
and what's nice about this example is
that we can demonstrate that
we start with a very basic model but by
adding this meta behavior to it
we are quite expressive in what sort of
model we would like to end up with and
we can see the effect over here as well
the orange line over here is what we
would get if we didn't do
any decay and what you can see here is
this green line
which fits the more recent data very
well but it doesn't really fit the old
data as much it doesn't really pay
attention to that
and that's because we're adding a decay
that's saying well
ignore the far away history and focus
on the more recent events one thing to
keep in mind
here is that by applying this trick you
will get this awkward situation where
it is possible that your training data
has way
worse performance than your testing data
and that is because you're probably
testing towards the future
and it's the future that we're actually
paying more attention to in our model
so don't be too surprised if that's
something that you see but the main
thing that i hope that you recognize
here
is that it's very nice to be able to
take models that we already know and
understand
and just add small interpretable
behaviors to it
it's that that gives us the opportunity
to customize a model to the use case
that we're interested in
and not only will that make our models
more accurate but it also makes them
just slightly more
interpretable which is always a good
thing
in this final segment we will talk about
a tool called human
learn and the whole goal of this segment
is to showcase that
you don't always need machine learning
back when data science was really just
starting out it wasn't really common to
use machine learning algorithms
instead what was more common is you
would start with a data set
and then you would get a domain expert
to come up with some business rules
and this would give you a system that
could automatically assign
labels to new data that came in these
days though
it's a little bit more common to not
write your own rules but instead to have
a machine learning algorithm figure them
out
you would collect data as well as labels
and then it will be the job of the
machine learning algorithm to figure out
what the appropriate rules are the
question is though
in this transition from a rule-based
system to a machine learning model
have we maybe lost something along the
way and there's a couple of issues if
you think about it for starters machine
learning isn't perfect
it might be that the machine learning
model is very accurate
but that it has behavior that we aren't
necessarily proud of
think of themes like fairness and it
might also be a little bit ineffective
odds are that if you're starting out
with data science and you've got a use
case
that there's also a domain expert around
who can pretty much tell you what rules
already should matter
if nothing else it would be nice if we
can construct rule-based systems in such
a way
that we can easily benchmark it against
machine learning models
so that got me thinking maybe we need to
have a tool that makes it easier to
write these rule-based systems
and that is why i started this new open
source project called human learn
the goal of the project is to offer
scikit-learn compatible tools
that make it easier to construct and
benchmark these
rule-based systems it is made in such a
way that it's also easy
for you to combine these rules into
machine learning models as well
and in this series of videos i would
like to highlight some of the main tools
of the package
and how you can get it working in your
daily flow
what i've got here is a jupiter notebook
and one thing to observe is that
at the top i have this pip install human
learn command
and it's this command that makes this
ulearn package available to me
what i'm doing in this notebook so far
is somewhat basic
the main thing is i'm loading in this
low titanic function
and that allows me to load in this data
set about the titanic disaster
the goal of the dataset is to predict
whether or not a passenger
survived so we have a column here that
we would like to predict that's binary
you survived or you didn't and there's a
couple of things that we have at our
disposal in order to predict that
we have the passenger class we've got
the name
gender age and what we can do is we can
take all of this data and put it into a
machine learning model
and look for a prediction however if i
were to come up with a simple domain
rule that might also go ahead and work
then i could argue that perhaps i can
also just have a look at this column
here
that tells me how much somebody paid
something's telling me that the people
who paid more for a ticket are probably
also the ones who were perhaps
more protected odds are that they were
on the upper decks
and i can definitely imagine that they
had better access to lifeboats than
everyone else on the ship
so that means that i could already come
up with a
rule-based system i could say hey
let's just have a threshold on this fare
and everyone above the threshold
survived and everyone below the
threshold didn't probably the easiest
way to implement this logic in python
is to write it down as a function which
is what i've done here
i'm assuming that a data frame goes in
as the first argument
and then i have this threshold parameter
and
effectively all the logic of predicting
is happening
in here if you paid more than the
threshold
then i'm assuming that you survived and
i'm returning in numpy array
and what i could do is i could just say
hey
let's apply that fair based function to
my input data x that i've defined here
and i will get all sorts of predictions
here
the issue with this is that this is a
function
it is not something that psychic learn
is able to accept
as a classifier and that means that i
cannot use it in a grid search or
pipeline and that's a bummer because i
would really like to be able to grid
search
this threshold hyper parameter over here
lucky for us though
there's a tool inside of humanlearn that
addresses this
the tool that we want to use now is
called a function
classifier and i'm importing it here
what the function classifier will do is
two things it will take
a function that you've written that
outputs a prediction
and it will turn it into a scikit-learn
compatible classifier
the second thing that it will then do is
it will also make sure that
any arguments that you've defined here
when creating the function classifier
that overlap with the arguments in the
function itself
that those arguments can be grid
searched
so to say and to show you how it works
what i've done
here is i've created a somewhat simple
grid search
i'm doing two cross validations and i
have a parameter grid here over the
threshold
effectively i'm looping over lots of
values between 0
and 100 and what i'm doing is i'm
keeping track of the accuracy
the precision and the recall and what
this grid search will do is it will pick
the best hyper parameter
based on the accuracy when i call dot
fit over here the system will run
and then i can inspect the grid search
results
the grid search just ran and i'm taking
the
results from it turning it into a data
frame and then making a chart
what you see on the x-axis over here is
the threshold value
that we set on the fare column and then
you see three lines
the blue line is the the orange line is
the precision
and the green line stands for the recall
one thing that we can see
is that when we increase the threshold
the precision
goes up that's the orange line and this
suggests that
the rule that we started with isn't half
bad people who paid more for the ticket
are probably more wealthy and are
therefore perhaps more likely to get to
a lifeboat quicker
now as a model this isn't necessarily
perfect
the recall that we have down below here
decreases the higher we set the
threshold
and that's also because there's less and
less people that paid a certain amount
for
it but all in all this is already kind
of nice
because it allows us to test if machine
learning models
can make better or worse decisions than
domain experts
and quantifying that can be nice a final
thing to mention about this
is how general this is we can come up
with
any python function that we like here
that has any logic that can cause a
prediction
and then any argument that we have in
the function can be used
as a hyper parameter inside of a grid
search
and this in practice can be very
very powerful the function classifier is
meant to be very customizable
that means that you can do more than
just come up with
a system that can make predictions you
can also use it to add behaviors to
existing models for example let's say
that i already have a classifier
and that i also have a outlier detection
system
something that might be really sensible
is that you first check for a new data
point
whether or not it is an outlier if it is
that you then say well
let's not make a prediction let's fall
back and if it's not an outlier
it might also be good to check if the
model's certainty
or the proba that's in the model if that
is high enough
and if it isn't that might also be a
nice reason to
perform a fallback scenario only when
these two checks pass
then should we take the action that the
original classifier takes
if you want to construct something like
this and you already have an outlier
detection model
as well as a classifier then the
function
classifier object can also be used to
very easily
declare systems that do exactly this
to give an example i have written down
the pseudocode that you might need to
construct something like this
i'm assuming that you already have your
outlier detector
and i'm also assuming that you already
have your classifier
but then if you want to construct the
diagram that we had before
the only thing you have to do is declare
this one
make decision function inside of this
function the first thing that needs to
happen
is you first need to have a classifier
that makes a prediction on
all the data points that are passed in
next if there is
any doubt that is to say we calculate
the probability values for each class
and if the maximum of all those
probability values is less than a
threshold
well then we are going to
not use the predictions that we had
instead we are going to overwrite it by
saying well the class
is now doubt fallback and the numpy
where function makes it really
convenient
to write this logic we also like to make
sure that it's not an outlier
so we apply a similar trick if we have
an outlier detection
model that's pre-trained we can make a
prediction and if the prediction says
it's an outlier
then we can assign another label instead
of the
original predictions this gives us our
make decision function and our function
classifier
makes it very easy to then accept that
function and we now have a fallback
model
that you can use in scikit-learn grid
search like you're used to
now i hope you agree that designing
systems like this
is beneficial in practice it is really
nice that we can add our own little
logic
in front of a existing machine learning
model
because that allows us to give a
behavior that we are interested in
i also hope it makes it clear that the
goal of this package isn't to make
rule-based systems that act as if
they're just predictors
instead we want to construct rule-based
systems using pre-existing machine
learning models
the idea being here that this gives us a
nice balance between
natural intelligence and artificial
intelligence
let's consider another way of
constructing rule-based systems
and to explain this i will be using a
data set
that is in the scikit lego package
now to get the data that we're
interested in what we got to do is we
got to
import this load penguins function all
we can do then is we can
call the function like you see here
and this gives us a data frame the goal
of this data set is to predict the
species of penguin
based on the properties of the penguin
like the
body weight or the length of the flipper
to get a different view of the data set
though what i'm doing below
is i am using this module inside of
human learn the experimental interactive
module
to generate some interactive charts
and here you can see one of these
interactive charts
i'll just zoom out a bit and the
interactive chart that you see
here shows these different
classes appear for the different kinds
of penguins that we have
now one reason why people like doing
machine learning is because it's kind of
hard to come up with
a rule-based system that can handle data
points like this
writing an if-else statement that will
perfectly describe this
area over here is relatively tricky
but what if we could just go ahead and
draw it instead
if i'm to consider this data set over
here i can argue that it's not really
that complex
as a human i can kind of draw the area
where i expect the green dots to be in
and i can pretty much eyeball what the
algorithm should look like
and that allows me to draw out these
polygons to get started with
drawing i got a selected color that i'm
interested in
in this case red which corresponds to
this class
and then i can double click and click
and click
click click click and when i'm done
making the polygon i can double click
once more
and then i've got a shape i can click
and drag this shape if i'm interested
and what i can also do is i can use this
edit button over here
to edit the shape but the main point i
want to make here is that
we can also declare rules by drawing
them
and this is just one drawing but let's
also make another one
and now i've got these two drawings that
as far as i'm concerned
should serve as a pretty okay
classification algorithm
now to use this as a classification
algorithm it's useful to point out
one more thing note that we added a
chart to this clf object over here
and that object is this interactive
charts object the one that took the data
frame as input and
this species as a label column what i
can do
is i can take that object and ask it for
all the polygons that i've drawn so far
using this json blob we can reconstruct
the drawings that we made
and we can use a point-in-poly algorithm
to check if a new point is in one of
these
polygons at any given point and if
that's the case
we can make the appropriate
classification
to get this to work though we're going
to have to import something called an
interactive classifier
the idea behind this classifier is that
we can define a scikit-learn compatible
model from this json blob
and what we can then do is we can
generate our
x and y data sets as we would normally
from a data frame and then we could use
this model as if it was any
cycler model that we're used to
and to emphasize how these
classifications work i've added a little
bit of code that makes the matplotlib
charts
and you can verify yourself that the
plots that you see here
do correspond with the drawings made
earlier in this notebook
it deserves to be mentioned though that
these drawn models have properties that
you might not have thought of up front
and some of these properties are
actually quite beneficial
what i'm doing now is i'm taking the
exact same model as i drew before
but now i'm having it predict a new
example
over here and this new example is
predicted
with a class of adelie and we can see
that it's doubting between
two classes in particular if i were to
scroll up now
then i can also explain why compared to
this chart
the new example point that i've made is
somewhere over here
whereas for the other chart the same
point will be somewhere around here
so that explains why it's having trouble
making a proper classification
but let's now say that the data that i'm
getting in
it's incomplete it's missing a value
well in this case if this was the value
that's missing
then i could scroll back up
to here and then where before the point
was inside of this polygon
it now isn't anymore so this chart is
not giving us any more information
for our classification task however
because these two variables
are definitely known we can definitely
still say that
the penguin is in this region and from a
machine learning perspective
that means that our drawings are robust
against
missing data
we now see that we're predicting a new
class and that's because
we are now zooming in on these two
features and no longer using
these two there is another use case for
these drawn
machine learning models so to say if we
have a look at the drawing right here
you'll notice that there's a couple of
points that kind of fall outside the
polygon that we drew
and in this particular case we can
perhaps make the argument
maybe some of these points are outliers
especially if we were to zoom out
i hope you recognize that this machine
learning model
really only has a comfort zone around
here
if we were to see points that are
definitely on the outskirts of this
comfort zone
then it'd be nice if we can have a
system that says hey that's an outlier
we should treat those points differently
luckily for us what we can do is we can
take the same drawing that we use to
make a classifier
and use it as an outlier detection
system where before
we would check whether or not a point
was inside of a polygon in order to make
a decision
the outlier detector will check whether
or not the point is
outside of polygons and there's a hyper
parameter we can specify the minimum
number of polygons that a point has to
be in
in order for it not to be an outlier but
to give a simple demo of this feature
you'll notice below here that i am using
the interactive outlier detector as
opposed to the classifier
and then i'm following very similar
steps as before but the main thing that
you'll notice now
is that when i make the chart of the
predictions
that all the points on the outskirts are
indeed
now classified as an outlier and again
what we could do is we can make changes
to
this drawing over here and then we would
get different results
in all the drawings that we've made so
far we've had the luxury of this
label that was available however you can
also imagine situations
where we don't have a label readily
available and in these situations it
might be nice to use this drawing
mechanic
to actually assign labels to data points
so as a demo
let's just add group 1 and
group 2 as labels here
because the labels parameter here is now
a list
these interactive charts will no longer
internally check for a column
and instead it will assume that these
are the
values that you want to assign so if i
now were to run this
you'll notice that the colors in the
chart here are gone i do however
still have the ability to make a drawing
like before
and i can use this drawing to make an
outlier detector
or a classifier but what i can also do
is use this drawing in a pre-processing
step
human learn comes with this interactive
preprocessor
and just like in the examples before it
is able to read in this chart data
but instead of acting as a predictor it
can act as
either a scikit-learn transformer
but it can also be used in a pandas
pipeline as you see below here
in the case of pandas what will happen
is it will add
two new columns with counts how often
a data point was in a polygon and if i
were to use the scikit-learn flow
instead
i would get the same counts but as a
numpy array
now this interactive charts api is
relatively experimental
currently it only allows for 2d charts
but you can imagine that
other visuals will also be added in the
future things like histograms can also
be used to make selections
the main utility of this library though
is to maybe start thinking a little bit
differently about machine learning
models
and to maybe start thinking about
rule-based systems instead
the goal isn't to throw machine learning
out the window but instead to use
machine learning algorithms
with some business rules around them
such that literally
machine learning models can play by the
rules
i hope you enjoyed watching these videos
on scikit-learn
it's a vast ecosystem and we've only
really been able to scratch the surface
here
but i hope that i've been able to
explain enough for you to either get
started or to explore the tool more
if you enjoyed these videos then i would
like to mention that there is some other
machine learning content out there that
you might also appreciate
in particular i make a lot of videos on
the calm code website
so definitely feel free to check that
out
also if you're interested in learning
more about natural language processing
then you might also appreciate the
videos i've been making on the official
spacey channel
in this series of videos i'm trying to
make a model that can attack programming
languages
and if that sounds interesting
definitely feel free to check that out
as well
and if you're interested in learning
more about natural language processing
definitely feel free to check out the
algorithm whiteboard channel on youtube
it's a playlist that i maintain on
behalf of my employer
raza and you'll find many examples and
explanations of
algorithms there as well if your
interest is to learn more about
psychic learn though then i might also
have some other recommendations
for you for starters definitely feel
free to
check out free code camp i've been in
industry for over seven years
but i still find many useful courses and
hints
on a wide variety of topics on this
website
which includes related toolkits like
numpy
and pandas second i might also recommend
checking out the pi
data youtube channel understanding how
psychic learn works is great
but sometimes you would also like to
hear anecdotes and lessons learned
from applying psychic learning practice
and the pi data channel
on youtube is a great resource for just
that
now the third and final resource that i
really recommend
is the psychic learn documentation page
scikit-learn is a gigantic library and
there's a lot of features that to this
day i still discover
basically just by reading the
documentation but there's also something
specific about the documentation
that i would like to highlight if you go
to the documentation page you'll find a
couple of sub-sections
there is a user guide that you can
follow but
there's also a subsection over here
under more
where it reads related packages
you see psychic learn isn't just a
package
at this stage you could also say it's an
ecosystem and there are many different
projects for specific use cases
that might seriously help out there's
experimentation frameworks
tools for model selection there's also
extra support for tools that have to do
with time
series and although the list of tools
here can be intimidatingly large
i really do recommend just having a look
here simply to get a feel of
what you could do with scikit-learn so i
hope you'll give this documentation page
a glance
and once more i hope that you'll be able
to use scikit-learn
to do meaningful work with machine
learning thanks for listening